Putting together a probabilistic
model--
that is, a model of a random
phenomenon or a random
experiment--
involves two steps.
First step, we describe the
possible outcomes of the
phenomenon or experiment
of interest.
Second step, we describe our
beliefs about the likelihood
of the different possible
outcomes by specifying a
probability law.
Here, we start by just talking
about the first step, namely,
the description of the possible
outcomes of the
experiment.
So we carry out an experiment.
For example, we flip a coin.
Or maybe we flip five coins
simultaneously.
Or maybe we roll a die.
Whatever that experiment is,
it has a number of possible
outcomes, and we start
by making a list of
the possible outcomes--
or, a better word, instead of
the word "list", is to use the
word "set", which has a more
formal mathematical meaning.
So we create a set
that we usually
denote by capital omega.
That set is called the sample
space and is the set of all
possible outcomes of
our experiment.
The elements of that set
should have certain
properties.
Namely, the elements should
be mutually exclusive and
collectively exhaustive.
What does that mean?
Mutually exclusive means that,
if at the end of the
experiment, I tell you that this
outcome happened, then it
should not be possible that this
outcome also happened.
At the end of the experiment,
there can only be one of the
outcomes that has happened.
Being collectively exhaustive
means something else-- that,
together, all of these elements
of the set exhaust
all the possibilities.
So no matter what, at the end,
you will be able to point to
one of the outcomes and say,
that's the one that occurred.
To summarize--
this set should be such that, at
the end of the experiment,
you should be always able to
point to one, and exactly one,
of the possible outcomes and say
that this is the outcome
that occurred.
Physically different outcomes
should be distinguished in the
sample space and correspond
to distinct points.
But when we say physically
different
outcomes, what do we mean?
We really mean different in
all relevant aspects but
perhaps not different in
irrelevant aspects.
Let's make more precise what I
mean by that by looking at a
very simple, and maybe
silly, example,
which is the following.
Suppose that you flip a coin
and you see whether it
resulted in heads or tails.
So you have a perfectly
legitimate sample space for
this experiment which consists
of just two points--
heads and tails.
Together these two outcomes
exhaust all possibilities.
And the two outcomes are
mutually exclusive.
So this is a very legitimate
sample space for this
experiment.
Now suppose that while you were
flipping the coin, you
also looked outside the window
to check the weather.
And then you could say that my
sample space is really, heads,
and it's raining.
Another possible outcome
is heads and no rain.
Another possible outcome is
tails, and it's raining, and,
finally, another possible
outcome is tails and no rain.
This set, consisting of four
elements, is also a perfectly
legitimate sample space
for the experiment
of flipping a coin.
The elements of this sample
space are mutually exclusive
and collectively exhaustive.
Exactly one of these outcomes
is going to be true, or will
have materialized, at the
end of the experiment.
So which sample space
is the correct one?
This sample space, the
second one, involves
some irrelevant details.
So the preferred sample space
for describing the flipping of
a coin, the preferred sample
space is the simpler one, the
first one, which is sort of at
the right granularity, given
what we're interested in.
But ultimately, the question
of which one is the right
sample space depends
on what kind of
questions you want to answer.
For example, if you have a
theory that the weather
affects the behavior of coins,
then, in order to play with
that theory, or maybe check it
out, and so on, then, in such
a case, you might want to work
with the second sample space.
This is a common feature
in all of science.
Whenever you put together a
model, you need to decide how
detailed you want your
model to be.
And the right level of detail is
the one that captures those
aspects that are relevant
and of interest to you.